foreign
[Music]
last week selected d23 attendees were
treated to the first moving images from
the upcoming MCU movie the Marvels
following the introduction of Monica
Rambo in one Division and Kamala Khan
and Ms Marvel the two will soon be
reunited with Carol Danvers AKA Captain
Marvel in the presence of the three
actresses and Kevin feige they presented
the first trailer which we'll now
summarize for you based on the
eyewitness accounts right at the
beginning a surprise guest shows up
namely none other than Nick Fury Furious
supervising Rambo during a spacewalk
when she suddenly switches places with
Kamala Khan neither Fury norambo know
what is going on this is followed by a
lengthy showing of the post-credits
scene from Ms Marvel eventually Rambo
and Khan meet again whereupon Ms Marvel
tries to use her superpowers for test
purposes again suddenly swapping places
with her friend the two ruminate on why
when using their powers they seem to
randomly swap places no matter where
they are at the end of the trailer Carol
joins them and the three of them fight
against soldiers that strongly remind
find us of the cree from Captain Marvel
finally the three main characters are
shown joking with each other which gives
the film a rather humorous touch in
addition there are rumors regarding the
villain of the film According to some
media reports zawei Ashton could embody
the main villain Hala in the comics she
is one of the last Cree survivors and
even the Lone Survivor of the accuser
Corps although this has not yet been
confirmed it is still one of the more
feasible theories the theatrical release
of the Marvels is planned for July 28
2023
thank you
foreign
[Music]